We're gonna make jam today. Jam?
And we're cutting strawberries right now.
But you can stir it.
Stir it? Stir what? The sugar.
Eat the strawberry still.
Oh, that looks like mustard.
What are you doing?
Mixing it.
Haha.
You made your change?
Was your shower discovered?
Was your coffee right?
So we're still taking pills in the morning?
Did you lose pet long enough?
Throw up in the ocean town
purpose? At a dark in the sunlight
nothing but the water. That sunrise now.
Just to let you know that now.
Cause this town's up in ocean now.
Hey, I miss this place.
Face your head and your heart.
And my head still tells me when this pain in your songs would happen.
At the way that you would say.
If only baby there were cameras in the traffic lights.
It'd make me a star
start.